this next problem is a bit of a classic
and I've actually gotten multiple
requests to do some variation of this
problem so it says find the volume of
the largest open box open box that can
be made from a piece of cardboard 24
inches square so let me draw my piece of
cardboard that's not a llama I don't
want to draw it filled in so my piece of
cardboard is it's going to be a square
I'll draw it pretty big because I want
you to visualize it and it's 24 what did
they say 24 inches square so it is 24 by
24 square by cutting equal squares from
the corners and turning up the sides so
what are they saying well they're say
we're going to cut equal squares from
the corner so let's say we cut a and let
me see if I can draw this well so I'm
going to cut a square here and I'm going
to cut an equal size square there I want
to draw this neatly and then I cut it
equal size square there and then it cut
an equal size square there right there
so I'm going to cut out those corners
and then I'm going to fold up the sides
right just so you can visualize it so
those dotted lines are where I would
actually fold the box and then I would
end up with an open box and let's see
what the dimensions would be and and
that's actually what the whole crux of
the problem is so how big of a squares
should I cut out in order to maximize
the volume of the box well these are
equal sided squares that I'm cutting out
so let's say that each side is X so if
this is X then this is X this is X this
is X this is X this is X this is X this
is X and then what is going to be the
volume of our box that when we when we
fold up everything let me see so I'll
draw the base so this dotted square
right here that's going to be the base
right I'll draw it at an angle that's
the base and what are the dimensions of
the base
well this base is going to be the length
of this side of the cardboard minus this
X minus this X right
so this base right here that is going to
be 24 minus 2x right it's just the whole
length minus this minus that that's how
long that is and of course this is going
to be the same length this is going to
be that same length all of these sides
of the base are 24 minus 2x so it's 24
minus 2x and then and then this side is
also 24 minus 2x and then what is going
to be the height of this of this open
box that we're creating so let me draw
the sides of it it's open which means it
doesn't have a top to it right so we
have an opening here so you can kind of
see the inside of the box and what is
this height well when you fold these
flaps up when you fold these flaps up
the X the height is X right if you can
think about it
this side here there's really just a bit
of visualization this side right here
that you can view as this thing right
here I can even do it in different color
for you you can view this side this
front facing side is this right here
I'll just do a couple you don't have to
do all of the sides I don't think you
could view this side is this side right
here right it's folded up and then that
this back side is this back side and
that side there is that and this is the
base anyway so that is the volume of our
of our open box and we want to maximize
it so how do we do that well let's write
the volume is a function of X and then
take its derivative figure out where the
derivative is zero and hope that that's
a maximum point and we'll prove it by
taking the second derivative seeing now
we actually want it to be concave
downwards because concave downwards
looks like that so that means you found
a maximum point so we know that the
volume as a function of X I like writing
the big v's the volume is a function of
X is that side x you know you could view
it as depth times length times height so
it's X the height times you could the
depth 24 minus 2x times the width
24 minus 2x now let's see if I can
multiply this out it's probably the
hardest part about this problem so x
times was 24 times 24 it's I want to say
it's what is its 4 what I mean I
actually it's kind of sad but I've made
so many careless mistakes recently that
I don't want to make any more and I want
to get the right number so 4 times 4 is
16
4 times 2 is 8 96 0 2 times 24 is 48 6 9
Plus 8 is 17 576 that's what I thought
it was I should have memorized my times
tables up to 25 but anyway 24 times 24
is 576 576 and then we'll have 2 times
24
so that's 48 X but we have them twice so
it's minus 96 X right because 2 X times
24 minus 2x times 24 then minus 2x times
24 so it's 48 2 plus 48 so minus 96 X
and then finally the last 2 plus 4x
squared 4x squared and now we can
multiply the X's out and we get the
volume of the open box is let me put the
X term first 4x to the third I'm just
multiplying this out - 96 x squared plus
576 X let me erase this my I should have
been able to do that in my head anyway
I'm not too proud to show that I didn't
know that let's see so let me erase that
let me erase that and so what do we want
to do we want to take the derivative of
this figure out at what value X values
do we have a 0 slope and then test to
see if those were maximum or minimum
points if we have a maximum point at
that x value and if it's a global
maximum that we have found the x value
that optimizes the Vout the volume you
might want to graph these and experiment
with them and get them more into
intuitive sense of it but that's really
what we did and when we
found minima and Maxima and we did
concave upwards and downwards and all of
that so anyway what's derivative V prime
of X is equal to 12x squared this parts
the fun part 12x squared minus was it
180 192 192 X plus 576 plus 5 that says
576 and it's hard to read talk to read
for me so let's figure out where this
equals 0 so we want to know where 12x
squared 12x squared minus 192 X plus 576
is equal to 0 and the easiest thing to
do here is just to divide the whole
thing by 12 both sides because when you
divide 0 by 12 you still get 0 so you
get x squared
- what's 192 divided by 12
well 192 was 24 times 4 right it was 20
to 24 times 4 is what is is that right
24 no no 24 times oh I just go to 24
times 16 is 192 right actually I just
want to be I've been making so many
careless mistakes 12 wasn't when I do
112 72 or at 16 I should have been able
to anyway - 16 X plus well this was 24
times 24 so this is also you could this
would be 12 times 48 so this should be
plus 48 is equal to 0 and we could write
24 times 24 is 5 plus 76 so 12 times 48
right so now we just have to factor this
so what two numbers that when I add them
I get minus 16 and then when I multiply
them I get 48 positive 48 let's see 6
times 6 times let me make sure I did
this so 12 12 goes into 72 6 times
let me I just want to make sure I have
the numbers right as you can tell I
don't do these problems ahead of time
because I want you to see that I go
through the pain as you do so let me
make sure I 12 goes into 576 12 goes
into 576 what five four times 48 48 and
you get 96 12 goes into 90 right 48
times 12 goes I shouldn't have had to do
that but I've been making so many
careless mistakes
I haven't eaten dinner yet so anyway
maybe I'm just missing the easy factor
right because I have what numbers you
get 12 times Oh actually I just figured
it out twelve times four sometimes when
your brain is in calculus mode the
algebra 2 gets difficult so this is the
same thing as X minus 4 times X minus 12
is equal to 0 so at X is equal to 4
we're at some type of minima or Maxima
we're at some critical point and X is
equal to 12 now let me tell you
something you don't we don't even have
to look at the second derivative here
what happens when X is equal to 12 what
will happen to the volume of the box if
X is equal to 12 what is the length of
this base its 0 right because the length
of this base is 24 minus 2x so this
would be 0 this would be 0 so this this
is a point where we have a volume of 0
so you know that this is going to be a
minimum point and if you want to verify
it take the second derivative of the
volume and evaluate the second
derivative of the volume at 12 and you
will realize that we are concave upwards
and that x equals 12 is a minimum point
so you already know in all probability
the answer is x equals 4 and if you
really wanted to verify it you could
take the second derivative at x equals 4
and make sure that we are concave
downwards at that point right because if
we want a maximum point we want to be
someplace where the graph looks
something like that so we're at a
maximum point so what's the second
derivative V prime prime of X is equal
to 24 24x minus 192 and what's 24 times
4 it's
96 right so V prime prime V prime prime
of 4 is equal to 96 right 4 times 24
minus 192 G equals minus 96 so the
second derivative at this point is
negative which means that we are concave
downwards which means that this is a
maximum point and once again I challenge
you to find another value of x where you
get a larger volume and just to get it
into it intuition how large will this
box be well if X is 4 then each side is
24 minus 8 this would be 16 by 16 by 4
so that's that would be the optimal
volume for that box hope you found that
useful and I will see you in the next
video where I will do another
optimization problem this one is
especially fun see you soon